each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay so today we have Tim Matson from
Intel to talk to us about parallel
programming problem particularly
powdered parallel patterns Tim described
himself as an old applications
programmer I've known him for I don't
know at least 10-15 years and that must
make me older but anyway he's worked on
a wide variety of machines going all the
way back to the Cosmic Cube and the
crate to and the vector machines and you
know plat parallel platforms and in a
variety of languages everything from
Linda and strand and hpf and MPI and so
lots of experience and I think that's
the best way to really you know
understand why parallel programming is
difficult and different alternatives
currently tim is working in Intel since
1993 and he's their advance for parallel
computing and his current interest is in
the design of parallel pattern pattern
languages for parallel programming which
we'll talk about today okay thank you so
well thank you first off thank you for
inviting me to come here and talk to you
folks I'm I'm just based down the road
and DuPont so it's fairly trivial for me
to just bounce on down here and talk to
people so it's funny that I almost never
get here but hopefully that I can change
over time I suspect this might be a
little bit different than many talks you
get in that this this is an ideas talk
I'm throwing out some ideas I have some
firm beliefs on what we need to do to
solve the parallel programming problem
and some ideas on how we can get there
but we're not there yet and so I'm not
going to have a specific programming
language in specific technologies but
hopefully I can lay out a picture for
some of the things we need to do and
should be doing and my hope is is that
at least one or two of you out there at
the end of this talk will go yeah yeah
let's work together to make this happen
faster and solve more about that in a
second but i am from intel and therefore
i always have to start with the
disclaimer these are my own views they
are not Intel's views i did not have
Intel's lawyers go over this talk in
advance so if I offend you or make any
of you upset
blame me don't turn me into to Intel
please also I work in a research group
there's absolutely nothing I will say
that has anything whatsoever to do with
an intel product I just love that and I
have tried my best to keep this talk
completely free of Intel IP so I think
I'm safe so let's go and get started
here the medic or vision you know a year
ago I had to have three or four slides
introducing this I don't anymore you
know we all buy in Moore's Law is going
strong and you know what amazes me is
where we're already demonstrating
samples at 32 nanometers so we are
really sticking to this schedule and to
really understand what this means is by
2017 we should be making it to the
eighth nanometer process technology
which is mind-boggling even to
contemplate and that means 32 billion
transistors will be the integration
capacity and what this all comes down to
from indels point of view is what the
heck are we going to do with all those
transistors because the day people stop
valuing our transistor densities our
business model falls apart the business
model the industry falls apart all hell
breaks loose and life becomes miserable
so we got to figure out how to keep
those transistors being at high value
and you all know that that that means
many core and i want to emphasize i I'm
trying to stop getting to get people to
stop thinking about multi core which is
where you take SMP technology and put it
onto a single chip and think many core
where you have general-purpose cores
special purpose cores and an
interconnection fabric that ties them
all together it is crystal clear that
this is where we're going and therefore
from a software point of view from a
hardware point of view this is the
direction we need to start start
thinking so how many cores in many core
well you know dulquar 06 quad-core 07 I
had the unique privilege of being
responsible for the software team on
this 80 courtship so you know we're
already in the the dozens and hundreds
you know it's possible to build dozens
of course how many cores we ship of
course depends on what the markets ready
for and of course the market is not
ready for a beast like this but we
already have
on how to build them and are continuing
research to figure out how to how to
make them really practical but this is
not a new territory for Intel we've
we've been doing hundreds to even
thousands of cores you know spread out
over many machines we've been doing it
for a long time and i want to emphasize
this because i think some of you
especially younger folks i see some
gray-haired folks out there who you know
who've been at this for a while and have
a real understanding of this is really
really old but i think some folks
especially new to the field don't
appreciate just how old it is intel
shipped a commercial hypercube in 1985 I
think ncube just beat us to claiming to
be the first commercial hypercube we
were right after them so I mean 1985 is
a long time ago and you know we built
that we built some of the first
gigaflops ventually we built and for
some reason my picture doesn't show oh
man there it is why didn't it show the
first time you know eventually by 96 97
we built the world's first teraflop
machine with over 9000 processors so you
know we we know the hundreds to
thousands of cores range we know what it
takes from a hardware point of view from
a system operating system point of view
from a parallel programming point of
view this is old territory to us and of
course what it got us was membership in
the dead architecture society and I
really think it's important for people
to keep coming back and looking at
pictures like this because it's a been
there done that before you know in the
late 80s and 90s everybody was had to go
parallel it was the big band wagon we
all jumped in and I recognize some of
you probably were attached to some of
those companies that failed because as
you notice there aren't very many arrows
continue into modern times and the
companies with arrows continuing to
modern times like this one and SG I
don't look anything at all like they did
back in the heyday I think we can only
conclude that parallel computing is
toxic and are we uh turley nuts to be
going back into the space right now and
I think if we don't spend some time and
asking ourselves why did it fail in the
past if we don't understand that we have
no chance of getting it right this time
around and I really would like to get it
right
so I think clearly what went wrong there
we go what was the software you know we
we figured out how to build wonderful
hardware back in the heyday of massively
parallel computers but the software
never showed up now in the National Labs
where you had folks that could spend and
do whatever it took to get the software
they had all the software they needed
but we firmly believed back in the late
80s and 90s that every engineering
company from the oil industry to the
automotive industry to the
pharmaceutical industry that they would
all need and have a tremendous to
appetite for these systems but the
softer never showed up now so obviously
what we have to do is think about this
as a software problem it's not a
hardware problem we can build all sorts
of weird hardware but the software can't
take advantage of it then it's useless
can we generate the software
automatically parallel software
automatically it amazes me that even
today I hear people talking about how we
can have implicit parallelism where you
describe the algorithm declaratively at
a high level and then some magical tool
will turn it into a parallel program
look we know that doesn't work we spent
decades of research trying to make that
work why do we possibly think it would
work this time around I don't understand
it's a valuable research approach I'll
get that second it's a valuable research
approach I like people to keep doing
research and thinking about it but I am
NOT going to bet the future of my
company on someone figuring out how to
make this magic work where I can express
my program and can automatically
discover the concurrency so I just don't
think that's a line that I I see being
productive so really
don't have the data and all
with a really at the point where they
knew
how to represent their data put it in a
form that they can make it really
computer over it I mean seems like the
big difference between now and as good a
heck of lot more data well I so so your
question is is was the issue really a
lack of parallel software was it the
inability of handling the problem at the
data level and having the data that
could take advantage of it and I guess I
have to I mean I think I understand
where you're going with that but in
several industry sectors where we tried
really hard to get penetration of
parallel computing and failed and they
had plenty of data so I'd look in the in
several of the engineering disciplines
and in the pharmaceutical sector where I
did a lot of work the data wasn't the
holdup they had the data they understood
how to format the data they had the big
problems of the big data sets moving it
around was hard i mean the old saying
was an old MPP was like feeding a
supertanker with a drinking straw so
there were those bandwidth issues but in
terms of did they have the data did they
have the problems did they understand
the data and how to how to address them
in in these large parallel machines that
I don't think was the issue yeah really
sober or was just not cost-effective
because you industry after industry you
could say oh yeah they seemed like you
know they should be doing this but maybe
the failure was you guys just didn't
make it cost um no I have go ahead John
I think it's combination of hope I think
the problem is like you were saying it
was getting the data to the process I
think it was a difficult thing okay I
think that's where the machines been
performed well and you know you could
say that well we can have the right
tools in order to sort of collate the
data in the and the operations or maybe
we didn't have the right hardware which
made it difficult to move the data to
decision to the processors so I think
it's that the data movement the data
layout problem which was a difficult to
do and being caused the performance and
scalability to be so yeah respond in
that second but how much of that was
they couldn't do it and how much was
simply that you could do it cheaper on
commodity hardware when they rock
monsters no they're not commodities okay
wait wait wait wait wait they're a
commodity is defined as a product that
there's no distinction on what source
you buy it from other than price and a
microprocessor is not a commodity now
people commonly call it that but there
are real differences between an AMD and
Intel any right all right I'll get down
off that what bugs me is when people at
Intel column commodities and and it's
just like no just I know the market
calls them that but but it's very
important to us business-wise that
people don't think of them as a
commodity okay so several great ideas
here you know obviously I'm
oversimplifying so yes there were
problems where the data issues made
these machines in practical yes part of
the problem was that the that Moore's
law was just you know the microprocessor
is coming out once we hit our stride
with the pentium pro in the mid-90s and
then that follow on so finally we had a
processor that that really could do
floating-point well and fast that
created a pressure so that was a factor
but let me respond to the software
problem so because my my role at intel
has always been the applications person
who can speak the language of the
scientists and you can speak the
language of
computer and software architects and in
the pharmaceutical sector where I work
very very closely they had a whole slew
of programs they used all the time and
to the to the end user medicinal chemist
you know they had their their
productivity software that they were
using in their domain their molecular
dynamics there ab initio quantum
chemistry their process control flow
applications and pieces of them would
run on these machines but you wouldn't
get the whole thing running so it killed
the conversation about adopting
parallelism before it really even got to
issues of data movement and is it
competitive with other opportunities you
know the fact was the software wasn't
running on the parallel machine so it
made it really hard to go anywhere of
these conversations so all of these
factors were important but we couldn't
even get to the point of let's work
through those factors because the
software wasn't there to start the
conversation so it's no any rate the
softer was a huge was a huge huge part
of it all right so so it's a little bit
controversial in some circles especially
the younger folk are trying to really
push this thing of just a magical tool
will solve the problem but we know
better now I mean we've got years and
years of research our only hope is to
get programmers to write parallel
software behead people have to create
parallel software and at some level they
have to do it explicitly they have to
describe the concurrency and they have
to describe something about the way that
concurrency is going to be managed so
the solution of course was let's create
a new parallel programming language and
this is a slide I just love I went
through the literature and and and and
tried to gather together a lot of the
important languages you could find in
the mid-90s and to give you an idea of
what a parallel programming nerd I am
these are the ones that I've at some
point written software with so I mean
I've just it's ridiculous how many now
what I want to assert and what I want to
warn you all about is this was really
really bad this was a bad thing and I
want to convince you of that and ask the
question did this glut of parallel
programming languages help us or hurt us
and I want to describe what
I consider to be one of the most
important computer science papers of the
last few decades this is the drag or
grocery store study do people know had
people seen this study before okay good
this is really important and since
Microsoft is such a technology engine I
want you to really internalize what this
study told us so this was done by at
Stanford and it was in there it is a
marketing research group at stanford i
forget what department there in but what
they did is Draeger the drag or grocery
store and I guess it's Palo Alto or in
that neighborhood is one of these
gourmet specialty grocery stores it has
just the really high ends but specialty
items and they set up two displays of
gourmet gm's one display had 24 jars the
other display had six jars and the idea
was that a customer could come up sample
the jam and get a coupon for a dollar
off so if you think about this what they
could do is they could count how many
people walked into the store how many
people sample the jam and and how many
people eventually purchased so they
could easily gather that data so then
what they would do is they would
randomly swap the displays and they
would train graduate slaves to stand
there and to properly you know present
the product so they could see how these
two different displays worked now what
they found is that the 24 jar display
indeed attracted more people sixty
percent of the people who walked in the
store walked up and would sample at the
24 jar display whereas they only got
forty percent of the people with the six
jar display what is really critical in
what completely shocked them when they
did this study is that thirty percent of
the people who sampled actually
purchased with the sixth jar display and
only three percent purchased with the 24
jar display now this has been confirmed
time and again they went on and they did
other studies so this you know one could
argue that well this is just jam it's
frivolous but it's been confirmed with
401 k plans at businesses they would
look at companies with this huge complex
array of 401 k plans that you could
voluntarily contribute to or companies
that had three or four and they found
the company with three or four actually
had higher participation rates so this
has been
confirmed with with things that matter a
lot more than jam and they coined the
term that that what's going on here is
choice overload that there's a natural
human tendency when being when you
present a human being with too many
choices they'll just walk away it's like
ah it's too hard to make a choice now
I'm going to go away so now keeping this
in mind what do you think the response
was to this yeah I really think that
back in the 90s we hurt ourselves pretty
seriously and I don't want us to do it
now I think it's a good thing that today
now there's an hpc bias here I
understand but today really there aren't
that many parallel programming models
that are heavily used in hpc you know
there's of course the people who do hand
threading win32 api or POSIX threads in
the UNIX and Linux space if you want to
do compiler directives there's openmp if
you want to do message passing there's
NPI and frankly MPI trumps all the
others in the HBC space and then there's
these new kids on the block cuda has
really taken off but could it will
rapidly transition to open CL because
opencl is a standard it does
functionally pretty much the same stuff
as CUDA but it's an industry standard so
they're not tied to one vendor and then
interesting enough airline seems to
really be gathering momentum and it's
it's kind of the exception that proves
the rule because it it emerged from an
end user community it wasn't computer
scientists or people at a chip company
sitting down saying this is how I think
you should program it was a telecom
community had a problem and they created
a language to solve their problem and
then they rolled it outside so it's very
interesting how that one involved but
the fact is there's not very many today
and since choice overload is a very real
phenomena what I cautioned us in the
industry on Intel Microsoft all of us
out here working on this problem is new
languages for research or great that you
know please spin off as many languages
you can and keep them inside your walls
and and study them and figure out what
works and what doesn't work but when
you're ready to deploy to the outside
world
is more we can actually damage ourselves
by spinning too many out this worries
because it Intel right now I'm aware of
seven different parallel language
projects and I shudder to think if we
try and turn them all out i bet you guys
have even a lot more than that yeah
subject dead useful i was you have no
product prevention oh really deck at a
department of product prevention i love
that that's good okay so so what i would
rather see people do the tendency in
parallel computing historically has been
if you see a language you don't like
make a new one and i ran into this back
when i was at Yale i couldn't attend i
couldn't attract graduate students very
well when i was on the faculty at Yale
because i wanted to do research and
usability I want to do research and how
effective different languages were and
they realized they'd have a tough time
when it was time to get the PhD if all
they knew was about how to use languages
no but if they created their own
language yeah yeah that was considered
PhD worthy work so I really think we
need to take on a different mindset and
and we need to think of how can we fix
what we have today before we turn to
something all new so a classic example
of this is open NP 2 dot 5 could not
handle the simple pointer following loop
like this it would be very it was very
awkward what you'd have to do to deal
with that construct so rather than throw
open and POA we amended it in open mp3
row so like all things in OpenMP the
parallel says give me lots of threads
the single says the following block
between the curly braces only one thread
will do so this thread goes through and
it creates tasks separate tasks to
process this loop so now I extended the
openmp and made it so that it can handle
these kinds of structures which are very
common in in modern software engineering
we fixed the API rather than throw it
away and create something new and I
would really you know this is less sexy
than coming up with the new whiz-bang
10mp but I I think we really need to
think that way of fixing what's out
there before instead of creating things
that are new I might add when I look at
language design I look at C C++ and Java
is all one family because to me the
programmer syntax matters what you do
under the cover whether it's
virtual machine or a just-in-time
compiler I could care less all i care
about is the code i right and i just i
love the fact that C sharp looked at
that same tradition and said how do we
make it better I mean that's the kind of
thinking that that I would like to see
extended to parallel programming take
what's out there and accept it and fix
it but patching up old api's is not
enough I mean I think that's a critical
step but there's more we have to do to
solve this problem one issue is what i
call the parallel composability problem
modern software is not written the way
old scientific software was meaning you
know in the old days what we used to do
is you'd have a team at some lab and we
be programmed would come in and the team
would sit down and roll up our sleeves
and we paralyze it in tune it now of
course software's written components
that come from many sources that come
from many languages so the parallel
programming idea of assuming that
everything is under one umbrella and one
program just falls apart and you have to
be able to compose individual modules
together I mean a good example of this
is the MKL library this is the math
library that Intel it has uses OpenMP
and if you had an open MP compiler built
with I mean an open MP program built
with the Intel OpenMP compiler calling
the MKL which to use OpenMP you could
not fit them together consistently what
I mean is you have oversubscription
problems you have all sorts of problems
there's no concept in the design of open
mb or the supporting runtimes for how to
compose modules so this is a huge
problem now I think the only sorts of
people who can solve it or people like
like companies like Microsoft's that
control their infrastructure and I know
you have a common concurrent runtime
project and I saw a presentation on it
and I felt like jumping up and
applauding because that is the only way
we're going to solve that is if things
map down onto a common runtime because
then you can do resource management and
handle the oversubscription problem and
you can handle data locality issues the
cut-across modules so i'm assuming you
guys are going to solve the
composability problem at least in your
universe and from Intel's point of view
that's good enough that's pretty cool so
that's
great so I don't need to deal with that
one but the other area which is how do
we intelligently evolved parallel
programming languages and ap is so that
they work for the mainstream
general-purpose programmers that's that
is the second problem and that's why
we're I think standards and and and
working across the community is is is
key and this is something that in sells
really good at because you know we're
software neutral and we can bring people
together from very different persuasions
and because of our nature of sitting at
the heart of the computer but you have
to someone else's GPU often sits there
and someone else's vendor is actually
selling the machine we're actually in a
really good position to work on this
problem how do we figure out how to
intelligently evolved parallel
programming infrastructure so that's I'd
like to talk about now when I look at
the history of parallel programming and
all those huge slew of languages you
would think we would have solved this
problem by now but we haven't and I am
convinced and and it takes me a long
time to develop why I'm so convinced to
this and I won't do that now but I could
walk you through it at some point I'm
convinced a huge part of it is that we
did not approach the problem
scientifically we did not approach the
parallel programming scientifically we
approached it as engineers if I had a
new idea for parallel programming
language what did i do I found some
graduate students and we created it and
then we wrote wrote some codes with it
then we published a paper and we jumped
up and down and patted ourselves on the
back and then we'd go off and we do the
next one and that's very you know it's
very effective if you're building
bridges and buildings it's not effective
if you want to develop a theory for how
to approve and evolve a technology for
that you need some kind of systematic
basis for comparing them you're
basically survival of the fittest has
been proven to be an incredibly
effective mechanism but you have to have
some way of deciding what's the fittest
and that means you have to have a way to
measure and assess and talk about
parallel programming languages and
compare them I think that's one of the
fundamental things we need to do and
that's one area I would love to work
with you folks on so
how do we compare parallel programming
languages today and I'm not going to
pick on a friend of mine at Intel
because he has a slide like this he used
to carry around a great deal no I'll
leave his name anonymous that some of
you may know who he is just from this
slide but he'll talk about his super
cool whiz-bang nested data parallel
language and look how superior to this
is to openmp and man that says
absolutely don't you really want to use
that nested data parallel but what does
this really tell us it doesn't tell us
anything he doesn't explain why the
openmp code was written that way he
doesn't tell us any performance data he
doesn't give us anything all this tells
us is that he prefers nested data
parallelism to openmp so okay we net we
get that I don't know how valuable that
is though so frankly I think I think my
colleague should be absolutely ashamed
for ever using a slide like this shame
on him shame on me this is a slide I
often use in my OpenMP talks look how
nice and elegant this OpenMP is but gosh
you know if I did it with the wind 32
threads API oh my god you don't want to
write this crap no way this is much
better so the point I try to make is
look we're all guilty of this we're all
guilty of engineering by potshots and
and that's got to stop if we want to
evolve the state of the art then we have
to support the state of the art with
systematic and careful sense of
comparisons so I'd like us to do it
right this time around I really feel
that we're on the cusp of a second
chance we blew it in the 80s and 90s we
meaning those of us doing research and
parallel software we created some great
stuff like size l and Linda and strand
and wonderful language is that nobody
used this time around I'd like to create
stuff that actually works and solves
problems and people really use so I'm
convinced that what we need to do is
create a systematic scientific method
for working on software in other words i
can put out a hypothesis i can test it i
can peer review it I can understand what
worked and didn't work so then I can
feed that back in and over time evolved
systematically to a parallel programming
technology that will really work that
Priscilla procedure has
never been done consistently in parallel
programming and that's what we have to
do and I break it down into these three
steps we first have to develop a way to
talk about how people solve parallel
programs we have to develop that human
angle what are the ways people attack a
parallel program what are the patterns
they use in building a solution we have
to create a way to understand that and
talk about it then we need to come up
with a jargon a terminology for how we
talk about programmability so that when
I'm sitting in a room of experts I don't
say gosh f sharp is just a nightmare I
couldn't imagine using that oh yeah well
OpenMP sucks you know it you got to get
to the point where you can really talk
about what's good about something what's
bad about something how the trade-offs
are made so we have to create that
terminology for talking about
programmability and then I'm going to
close just briefly with the plea that we
have to come up with metrics and
programmability metrics so let me go
ahead and walk through this now we found
in the early 80s when I started early
80s Early 90s gosh you know you know
you're getting old and you get off a
decade with things in the early 90s some
of you older people here will remember
the emergence of object-oriented
programming I mean you know the
technology was really really old but it
took off in the late 80s and early 90s
and in the early 90s I would
characterize the object-oriented
programming world is utter chaos it was
chaos because we had these different
languages out there which isn't bad
Smalltalk objective-c this weird thing
called C++ on but there is really no
idea how to really use them so so you
had these horribly expensive projects
the one that mentor graphics is the one
that because they're right next door to
where I was living then that I was most
aware of where they spent millions and
millions of dollars with teams of
Engineers redoing all their software in
C++ and then it didn't work they could
never get it working right and once it
did it didn't run very fast because
nobody understood how to really use
obdurate of programming and what you had
to do was write a whole bunch of
programs and fail many times and then
eventually you'd get it and you could do
object oriented programming and have a
lot of success
so a book came out in the mid 90s early
early to mid 90s on design patterns and
this is a famous book I have a feeling
if I went around to your cubicles most
of you would have this book on your
bookshelf it's the Gang of Four book on
design patterns and it almost overnight
got the object-oriented programming
field to grow up because now all of a
sudden if you were new to the field you
could read this book and you would know
the tricks of the trades that the
experts took for granted and that was
really valuable if you're trying to
learn object-oriented programming it was
also really valuable because if you had
a room of experts sitting around they
could say gee what do you think we ought
to use here well maybe the factory
method oh yeah okay so give a jargon
that the experts could use when talking
about their field so really it was
amazing to witness it as a software
engineer out there earning my living
writing software how almost overnight
object-oriented programming went from
chaos jungle cowboy land to systematic
engineering field now a design pattern
is is a solution to a problem a
recurring problem that captures the
excellence in a solution to that problem
so you mind patterns from excellent
solutions it's not necessarily anything
brand new it's just codifying what the
experts have worked out and make it
putting a name on it and writing it down
a standard way now this book was a
catalogue of patterns if you go back to
the origins of patterns they talk a lot
about a pattern language and i want to
emphasize the importance of a pattern
language a pattern language has the idea
of a flow through the language patterns
in turlock they fit together I have high
level patterns that lay out the solution
at a high level lower level patterns
they hierarchically nest and you flow
from high level down to low level
patterns as you go from the start of a
problem to the end so the catalog is as
I said you just look up and like oh
that's my pattern a pattern language is
I use this pattern which then flows me
to this pattern which then flows me to
this pattern so pattern language
includes this higher level knowledge on
methodology that's missing in this book
so what I did back in the
starting in late 90s and it was
published in 2004 is I attempted to do
for parallel computing what the Gang of
Four did for object-oriented programming
and I groped this book with Beverly
Saunders who is vastly smarter than me
and comes from the formal verification
community so she I want to do things
fast she wants to do them right so we
actually we're a great team and then
burn a massingill who I met when she was
a postdoc at Caltech an old applied
mathematician doing well she's not old
but an applied mathematician who does
lots of work in parallel programming so
the three of us wrote this book and it
is a full pattern language and one of
the fun things about writing it is the
examples are an MPI openmp and Java so
it's really fun to take a pattern and
see how you do it in these different
languages however the three of us
basically come from a scientific
programming background so if you read
this book today you would see that it
does a really good job of capturing how
the hold hpc era of parallel computing
did things so in some regards it's a
little bit narrow on scientific
computing even though that wasn't our
goal and we've learned a lot since we
wrote this book so what I'm doing right
now at the power lab at UC Berkeley is
to do the next generation to kind of
throw this away and let's do it right
this time but pay a lot more attention
to bringing in a broader community of
programmers so what comes out at the end
isn't for scientific computing it's for
all computing it's for general-purpose
computing now is everyone here familiar
with the power lab UC Berkeley some yes
some blank stares let me show you the
one picture about the power lab so the
par lab this is the group at Berkeley
that Intel and Microsoft are funding
through the UPC RC which I can never
keep all the letters straight but we are
together funding this company to the
tune of a big pile of millions of
dollars all right so you have a whole
team of very smart people who are really
excited about making sure that Microsoft
and Intel are happy so five years from
now maybe we'll give them more money so
i mentioned that though because i have
found to a remarkable degree
very very open to someone like me from
industry coming in and saying gee if you
thought about doing it this way and I've
they've changed they've made huge
changes in how they do things so I'm
really pleased at the extent to which
they are looking from input we're not
just money bags they really want us to
be direct collaborators and i am very
closely indirectly collaborating of them
so the way they're working things is
they have at the top a collection of
applications that are driving the
research the problem is to break that
they're addressing is to bring the world
to a point where you write correct
software that runs efficiently on many
core and they like to say that they're
addressing the single socket problem so
they're not trying to address the HPC
problems and the cluster computing
problems these are all very interesting
but let's just focus on the parallelism
that sits in a single socket so how do
we make that software routinely parallel
that's correct and efficient so they
have these applications at the top image
retrieval hearing and music speech etc
and what we're doing is we are analyzing
those applications and we're going to
create an understanding of how humans
think about them and how humans paralyze
them in terms of a design pattern
language bunch of course on a single
ship is that what you be missing
something that's only by single socket
yeah so lots and lots of course on a
single chip which I I mean they say I
gave you the words they use but but it's
not quite right so it's almost better to
call it a single board because they're
also really ends you got a GPU sitting
there let's use that too but the thing
is a lot of these people have
relationships up the hill at the labs
where everything is huge HPC and so they
need a simple slogan so when the HPC
people come to them they can calm them
down and say no no we really mean your
laptop your laptop your handheld device
is the single platform you share memory
or
yeah well maybe but I don't submit you
have to have shared memory so it's not
really yet I mean yes today the single
socket you tend to have shared memory
between all the cores but nothing says
it has to be that way so my research at
Intel is doing distributed memory
cluster on a chip and I'm finding that's
an incredibly productive architecture
but from a softer and a hardware point
of view this really is as hard as a PC
yes this problem is is definitely as
hard as HPC in many ways it's harder and
it's harder for sociological reasons
with hpc I have programmers who actually
enjoy enjoy the difficulty I mean if you
just have to visit one of the National
Labs and sit around with the programmers
and you'll hear them go like yeah man it
was great i was up till 2am getting that
routine debugged and I got it from 97%
to 97.5 percent speed up it was just
great they like that stuff but here you
have real-world programmers we have
deadlines to hit and they have to add
features and ship on time and it's a so
so the sociology is totally different
that these people will not will not take
the pain as the hpc remember maybe share
it on the caches chair you don't want to
cache miss so that's a separate issue
and and from a hardware point of view
that is the crux of the issues where
we're working on right now at Intel so a
lot of the I mean like the Intel
projects today our Intel products today
are shared cache not the L once they
have their own l1 but they have a last
level cache they share okay so yeah you
have l1 sometimes even an l2 that's per
tile that 80 courtship that I worked on
was shared nothing there's there is
there was no sharing at all I have a
research project going on right now that
we haven't released in public so I can't
say much about but it's kind of a hybrid
between it there's some sharing there's
not some sharing so I mean we're
basically exploring the design space
very broadly which is why I responded
your comment about well it means share
of memory well it doesn't have to mean
shared memory and when you look at the
overheads at managing a shared cab
rush you quickly get to the point where
you're eating up that bandwidth on that
on ship network just keeping track of
who has which piece of the cash and at
some point you have to wonder wouldn't
we be better off to just get rid of the
shared cache now I know I'm getting off
on a tangent but I think this is an
important tangent for people thinking
about how to do parallel programming I
have found anecdotally when I sit down
with old timers like me who've done tons
of shared address space programming and
message passing programming we prefer
the message passing then shared address
space why because in message passing any
time sharing occurs its explicit in the
text of the program I know sharings
occurred and if I don't have that send
and receive or communication routine
that I know I have isolation whereas in
shared address space programming it's
the opposite extreme there may be
sharing going on that I have no clue
about and there's nothing in the text of
the program to tell me so i think
there's this illusion out there among us
computer scientists pushing parallel
programming that shared address spaces
are a good thing and I don't believe it
I think in Pat fact they may be a really
bad thing and we may need to really move
away from them so shared memory may be
okay but I like the idea of a
partitioned global address space there's
a there's an address space you can get
to the memory it's shared but it is
apparent in the text of the program when
sharing occurs so there's a discipline
on how that sharing occurs so and keep
in mind as I say that I mr. OpenMP you
know I've spent the last 10 years
working on OpenMP and a shared address
space so in some regards it hurts me to
say this and my OpenMP people throw
things at me when I say this but I
really do think someday we will look at
this whole shared address space a trend
that started back in the in the 80s and
90s and and just think it was a big
mistake and throw it away so I don't
necessarily think it'll be shared memory
at any rate yeah
a shared game space has been the
foundation of traditional sequential
composition in which we bailed they're
built layer and software if we throw
that out are we throwing out all our
notions of modularity and layering that
went with it no no I don't think so at
all how about all the current software
that's built on top of those notions and
glaring well that becomes very difficult
that doesn't yeah um these easy invited
speakers is how I am memory there are
some ramifications yeah no I I'm keeping
quiet there are huge ramifications at
any rate at Berkeley van so you have the
applications at the top driving things
we have a design pattern language that
captures the idea of what those
applications are doing what the
concurrency is what the parallel
algorithms are then you have a lower
layer that they call the productivity
layer and the idea is that you have a
large universe of programmers who are
focused on just getting the job done
they're usually closer to a domain of
expertise not hard core computer
sciences definitely not hardcore
currency experts so they're living up at
this range here in the productivity
layer and the hope is is that they can
do a lot of what they need through high
level languages may be declarative
languages parallel libraries high level
frameworks you know this is where you
really need to raise the level of
abstraction and make it easy for the
general-purpose programmer then there's
a smaller number of programmers who work
at this efficiency layer they're the
ones who I would these are the
traditional HBC people you know the
advantage we had in the HPC world is
everybody was in the efficiency layer so
we didn't even have to worry about the
productivity layers because we didn't
care to be productive we just wanted to
be efficient so you know MPI low-level
languages threads they worry about how
do you get the performance up on the
libraries so auto-tuned errs to search
parameter spaces so so these are the
people at the efficiency layer who worry
about getting every last ounce of
performance at the productivity layer
they'll trade off performance for the
ability to quickly engineer software
care
we care greatly about protective but
they'll always throw it overboard for an
extra flaw you're right the age the HBC
people do I know I'm being slightly
facetious they do care about
productivity but they won't take protein
though they'll say things like I need a
new programming language it's got to be
easier to write software but then when
you give it to them they throw it away
cuz it cost them a few percent so I
often say that the HPC people are just a
bunch of whiners and that they should
just shut up and sit down with mpi and
leave us alone because really when it's
all said and done you just give them mpi
and they're off and running and they get
their jobs done and they do beautiful
work so I'm I'm frustrated by them but
on the other hand that's kind of my
people I understand them yes to layer
seem to gain by pretty much what the
database people have the database
manager database user oh where does this
compare I have no idea how this compares
the way the database people break things
down because I'm not a database
versatile so I mean haven't imagined
that if I looked at different slices of
computing they'd have a similar
breakdown and in fact I was at an open
CL meeting recently and one of the
interesting things for me about opencl
is we have participation from game
vendors so actually sit down and talk to
real gaining software developers I never
talk to these people and they were
talking about a technology programmer
that that a very key thing and then
producing a game is that the time from a
technology programmer is really really
expensive well when I probed them on
what they meant is the technology
programmers what they call the
efficiency layer guys and it's about 1%
of their programming staff and they pay
them a lot more so you know anyone
looking for job security yeah well learn
how to be on this layer they get they
get a lot more money and they do
everything in their power to minimize
the amount of time they have to go to
those technology programmers that the
bulk of their software developers are up
in this productivity layer and that
surprised me because inside Intel we'd
always been told that you know well game
developers there they got hit those real
time constraints they're very
performance centric but actually
increasing they're moving to not just
C++ but but scripting languages Perl and
Python and it's really bizarre but at
any rate day 2 we're talking about this
split but they're taught you know in the
Berkeley crowd we think 90
Center productivity ten percent or
efficiency in this gaming community they
were saying ninety-nine percent were
productivity and one percent were
efficiency so it seems things are
naturally migrating to the split and I
talked to people in the business world
and they've similarly said that there's
the split somewhere between 90 1095 five
percent between productivity and
efficiency layer not the financial
sector because a lot of that looks like
HPC and talking about business process
sales resource management point of sale
management and you know another area I
know as little about as I can get away
with Mathis toughest know that their
mamas you know right many times on so
they they do really
second mark intelligence
he always changing the other
in the financial sector well in so at
any rate finishing out this overview of
the Berkeley folks you have groups
working on applications you have groups
working on patterns you have groups
working on the productivity layer your
folks work in the efficiency layer you
have a group i just want to mention it
briefly cuz i'm really interested but
what they're doing is rethinking the
role of the operating system and saying
like well what if I expose the scheduler
as a first class item that the
efficiency layer people can manage
because you know most the time the
schedulers buried down on the OS and I
have very little way to interact with
that so it's very very interesting how
they're blurring this line here between
operating system and the efficiency
layer and and it's one of these areas
where I'm not participating in the
research but I'm watching it very very
closely because it's just it's
fascinating to me and some of the grad
students working on this or graduating
soon so if you're looking to recruit
some really interesting people that's
good place to look then they have a
architecture group so they really top to
bottom as what they're doing here in the
parlor and then we haven't heard much
from them but the whole idea is off to
the side we're going to people are going
to worry about correctness but I'm an
old HPC person I don't care about
correctness so it's like ah it doesn't
have to be correct just has to be fast
so what what we're doing and this work
I'm now describing is work I'm doing
with Professor Kurt quite sir and I
don't know if many of you know him but
he's very well known in the cad
community and spent like i don't know 15
20 years in the cad business before he
became a professor but what we're doing
is we realized that the problem we're
trying to solve is bigger than just
parallel algorithms which is really what
my book focused on was just how do you
how do people do parallel algorithms
what we really have to do if we're going
to address the the par lab mission is we
have to figure out the whole software
architecture angle how that looks from a
parallel point of view and so our
influences are you know the traditional
patterns community and my book
influencing on one direction so very
algorithm focused thought of patterns
the Berkeley folks broke down computing
into these 13 dwarves which political
correctness doesn't let them call them
dwarves anymore so I think they're
calling
motifs but basically the the 13 patterns
are common computational elements that
seemed to appear again and again across
domains and then we looked at garland
and Shaw who kind of had that classic
book that summarized software
architecture to high level and then
finally the influence that really came
in strong was the very original work by
Christopher Alexander on pattern
languages and this is where it all
started back in the 70s and Christopher
Alexander if I don't have you folks it's
actually a beautiful book to read and
it's actually very very interesting to
read because he was trying to capture is
he talks about that quality without a
name when you see something really
really special something inside of you
can tell that it's special and would it
be nice if you could get experts
together who understand that specialness
and if they can write it down and share
it so it's very much that that that
almost religious zeal for patterns and
pattern languages so you pull all of
these together and you end up with our
pattern language okay clearly that's a
working title but that someday we'll
give it a better name but opl stands for
our pattern language and in a very long
talk you know I've given patterns talks
many times and they're really hard to
make them interesting because they get
down into a lot of detail and they
quickly get kind of boring so the thing
to do is just look at it at a high level
and then come to me and i'll give you
more detail later i'll give you things
to read but the idea is that we're
trying to capture a language for the
architecture of parallel application
software we start at the top here in
fact let me advance to the next we start
at the top here with patterns that talk
about the large-scale architecture of
your application so pipe and filter
MapReduce layered systems these are
concepts if you know Garland and Shaun
have been reading software architecture
academically that will be very familiar
to you then over here we have the
computational patterns this is the 13
dwarves you know the idea is that if
you're familiar with the 13 dwarves it
started with Phil koala who recognized
and point and suggested that all
scientific computing was an instance of
one of seven archetypes that he called
the Seven Dwarves there's things like
dense linear algebra sparse linear
algebra unstructured mesh structured
mesh etc and what the Berkeley folks did
is they sat down and took that as a
starting point and said well you know if
we add six more we think we can cover
everything so they came that's where the
13 dwarves came in and then they would
invite people in from different
application domains to sit down with
them and go through the divorce to
trying to do a you know see if they had
coverage so they bring game developers
in they brought the folks I work with in
the workloads group and Intel and to
look at the RMS workloads they brought
in financial people open so they went
really spent some time validating to
themselves at least that these 13 doors
do a pretty good job of covering
everything and you know it's not cast in
stone in fact we're very interested if
someone looks at the list and says gee
you need to add two or three more the
list will grow the key thing is that
it's a number on the order of 13 it's
not a number on the order of 10,000 or
hundreds it's it's a manageable number
and these are the computational patterns
so the way I like to think of it is when
i'm at the architectural level if I'm
walking up to a whiteboard and I'm
describing my application to you at the
architectural level i'm drawing boxes
and arcs between the boxes then I'm
ready for the computational level now
I'm saying what's happening in each box
and so therefore there's an iterative
nature because I may as I start looking
at what's happening in each box gogi
those two boxes really should be merged
or maybe I should split this box apart
another way so we have these arrows here
these green arrows pointing out that
it's kind of a back and forth between
the architectural level and the
computational level until you've
described the architecture of your
application in terms of the major boxes
the connections between them and the
types of computations occurring in each
box you alluded to the motion
how that is so important yes programming
would you say that that's mostly a
concern of the left box the architecture
box um its composition mostly concern of
the architecture box I don't think so
but I'm not sure I think it can't be
just a concern of that box and the
reason I think it's hierarchical and
compositions going to occur at every
level I mean what I'm talking about for
example if I have a box and inside the
box is a spectral method that's one of
these patterns here well the spectral
method i'm doing a transform i'm doing
some computation than a bat transform so
now i'm composing inside the spectral
method several different routines well
now when you start looking at doing
higher dimensional transforms there's
composition that would occur inside
there so it's all hierarchical and
composition I think will influence I
think every every layer it'd be nice if
we could just say I can only worry about
it here and I think often I might get
away with only worrying about the
architectural level but to ultimately
solve the problem composition will touch
every layer of the patterns did you have
a question or comment I was wondering
filter the relation between the
architects trying to convey page
do you think those are fundamentally
different problems that need different
solutions because that's what it looks
like on this picture everything else is
sort of way over the top of each other
those two you have side by side so we
have those two side by side um and it's
kind of artificial because we're laying
things out in a clean stack diagram
because we have to get it onto a
two-dimensional representation and
depending on the problem things may
stack stack differently but I do think
you're talking about very different
things in these two cases and the
solution I think will look very
different because here I'm not saying
anything at all about what is computed
when I write the architecture all I'm
concerned about is what are the major
blocks and how are they connected
whereas over here it's all about what is
computed so I suspect the architectural
patterns will be pretty straightforward
for us to come up with some high level
frameworks or a wizard to build them
it's easy to think of some tools I can
build that will support this
architectural level hey you have a lot
more research done in the past
because that's our all 8 PC Perkins the
architectures that I think it's this
grab bag little technique
okay I'll agree with you that from a
research point of view in the parallel
world there's been very little in the
architecture side but I just when I
conceptually sit back and think about it
I mean the fact that i'm talking about
it as i'm drawing boxes on a whiteboard
well it's pretty easy for a wizard to
look at that boxes representation I mean
heck look at visual basic you know
imagine a visual basic like front end
where I just sort of pull down I pull
down little icons and connect them
together and bam it creates my framework
for the high level architecture it's
figure out how is Theta being sharing
between those boxes it's very difficult
to take an existing application
reverse-engineer it into this so and
that's a process where we're going
through now is is validating this design
building case studies by looking at
existing applications so but I respond
to that on two bases on in two
directions I gave it my response on
looking at existing applications we're
finding it is very difficult and it's
difficult because they compose together
in complex ways and it's also difficult
but but but it's also difficult because
people writing software don't think
architectural e we do a very bad job
especially in hpc we've done a very bad
job at thinking about a software
architecture in hpc and that's where I
come from we would use a monolithic
architecture which means no architecture
we just start writing code and merging
loops and and so I would say that part
of what I'm looking at with this is
people writing new code and trying to
influence people to write new code
differently and that for writing new
code I would like them to think of an
architecture and then move through here
if I only solved the new code problem
I'd be successful hold the question
remains how do you vote out the right
extractions to fill your architecture
that is the question and we think we've
got we think we've got them or we think
we've got a great start at them and what
what we're doing right now is is testing
that theory now let me emphasize for
those of you who haven't been in the
patterns community long which is
probably all of you or most of you in
the patterns world we describe the
process as pattern mining so a pattern
is not something you sit down and go I
think this is how it should be patterns
are always mind from excellent solutions
so if you look at the things here and
you start reading them and you go G data
parallelism that's not new pipeline come
on people be doing that for ages yeah
okay good good if you look at this and
you see stuff that's totally new then we
failed because it should capture
excellence in existing solutions and and
so that's what we consistently do we go
out and look at excellent solutions and
we mined them we understand the patterns
and we either validate that we have the
right patterns in the right places or
revalidate we need to add new patterns
and this is the process where we need to
grow the community and get more people
in because with my book there were the
three of us and we came up with
something very nice for the stuff the
three of us had seen many many times
which is useful but it's not enough
what's enough is to get a large
community together and really boil down
around a consensus of what are these
basic building blocks yes the solution
how do you know a solution is excellent
um you know it when you see it yes that
is scientific yeah a community see the
consensus in a community sees it as
excellent but yeah that is that is
subjective i mean we're capturing the
human element here so when you were
saying that you didn't care about
correctness on the HBC world clearly
what performance it's an excellent
solution would be one that ran blazing
fast but perhaps somebody was formerly
inclined and great about prepositions
angle oh this is bad that's right that's
right you're absolutely correct in that
that excellence is in the eye of the
beholder and and therefore there is a
subjective factor this is very
subjective when you start talking about
design patterns you're stepping over
from the the world of the typical
computer scientist where everything is
clean and objective and and very very
systematic to the fuzzy things are vague
maybe you can take it this way maybe you
can take it that way but you know that's
critical because what am I trying to do
here I'm trying to capture that human
angle that we've traditionally done such
a terrible job at capturing so I'm
trying to get it and write it down but I
need to keep going as we're almost well
we're almost out of time and you're
almost out sick of listening to me I'm
sure so this is just an example and an
oh my I learned long ago if you ever see
a typo in a slide you have to fix it on
the spot or you'll never never fix it
okay so this is a one slide example and
I'm not going to walk through it just
just because of the lack of time but
looking at the CAD universe you have an
overall pipe and filter architectures so
that's what you see with the boxes here
and then inside the boxes you have these
computational patterns that appear and
that this one picture actually
summarizes a huge amount of what happens
in the cad space and it's an example now
of how we've boiled down the problem
into a form that we can go through and
start systematically analyzing and
working through instead of just this
very confusing mess that is the cat
applications
the patterns give us a way to precisely
describe the computation which is
valuable for the experts sitting around
talking about how do I support this in
the software world and how do I build an
infrastructure to support it and it's
valuable to the person new to this field
is trying to learn it but it also gives
us a way to compare and contrast
remember that old programmability thing
I started with now remember earlier I
could I just said you know I open mp's
great windows threads suck or you know
OpenMP is awful and data parallel
programming is great well now I can
actually go through and I can look at
different patterns and I can say look
how well does this notation support
programming in that pattern now it's
still a little subjective but now I've
laid my assumptions out on the table for
us all to sit around and argue about so
four or five of us sitting around with
experience with each one of these could
could discuss and argue it and trade off
until we came to a consensus on how
these things play it off and so you can
see if I'm doing SPM d-style programming
G everything works great ok but if i'm
going to do you know an actor's type
architecture well GMP I is great for
that NP i can do anything right MPI is
great for that opencl be absolutely
abysmal and yeah OpenMP maybe I could do
it but it really doesn't support it well
so I give it a redbox even though I know
openmp very well I know how to trick
OpenMP and doing actors but I'm tricking
it to do it so it's not fair to say it
can do it so this gives me a way when I
have a collection of programming models
to compare to lay them out against a set
of patterns that I care about and now
I've productively said something about
these languages rather than I prefer
OpenMP and everything else sucks so I
think it's a huge step in the right
direction and let's see gosh I thought
ahead because we're running low on time
I can't believe it I lost it was a great
slide to this is what happens and you
pull slides together at the last minute
is that slide hidden oh it's down here
okay I'm sorry folks so let me just go
on all right now I want to emphasize
is that to us at the par lab the
patterns are a means to an end they're
not an end in and of themselves so I
think they're valuable and they're
valuable for talking about
programmability but the other thing that
we really like the patterns for is they
give us a road map for the frameworks
that will support the productivity layer
so in our vision of where this will go
you know the three years from now we're
near the tail end of the five-year bar
lab period you know I we're hoping that
we get to a place where you have this
small number of hardcore technology
programmers that produce these parallel
programming frameworks and I'll use the
word framework very loosely it can be a
you know a language supported by a set
of library supported by a wizard I mean
it's software technology to support
parallel programming and then you'll
have a domain literate Computer Sciences
to who understands kind of the bridge
between the hard layer efficiency and
what a domain needs and they're going to
work at the parallel programming
frameworks to create these application
frameworks and then my end user programs
we know nothing about parallel computing
and our goal I don't think it's possible
but the Berkeley people do is that that
domain expert doesn't even know they're
writing parallel code a domain expert
just has this parallel application
framework it's been given to them and
the parallelism is buried inside of
there I don't believe that's possible
but I believe it's a good goal to shoot
for and I believe if we only get ninety
percent of the way there so they may be
only say a little bit about the
parallelism and all the details can be
buried then we've been very successful
but I'm hoping that the design pattern
languages we're talking about but we're
working on will be the roadmap for
building this hierarchy of frameworks
and that's the end goal in the par lab
for the for the patterns and I'll skip
that and so the status of where we are
with that language is we're quite
confident about the overall structure
it'll need a little tweaking and moving
around and we may need to change some
definitions but that picture I showed
you with the pattern language we feel
pretty good that that's pretty close to
right on the top level patterns we have
good drafts for most of those the bottom
level patterns some of them come
straight out of my book and therefore we
some of them still need to be written
but this term i'm teaching a course at
UC berkeley where we're basically
writing the rest of that pattern
language we have the descriptions we
know what they are but you know if any
of you have ever written a pattern
writing a pattern down is a very
involved in difficult process it's very
fulfilling actually I mean it I find it
very satisfying because you have to do a
lot of research to make sure you really
have found that nugget that
characterizes the good solution and
finding it understanding it and writing
it down like writing a good tight piece
of poetry so what we'd like to do is
really get more people working with us
from a broader community we want to grow
the pool of people that are working with
us on this language because that's the
only way we'll be a consensus for how
how this field works so we have at
Berkeley these all day pattern workshop
the next ones coming up coming up March
18th then we have one on April 22nd so
you're all welcome to join I I would
love to have the problem a turning
people away because we have too many
that'd be great problem and then we're
having a conference para plop which will
call for papers will be going out soon
it'll be in santa cruz June 4th and 5th
which is after the power lab summer
retreat so you know we're actively
growing the community to wrap this thing
up so we're running out of time here so
let's let me mention briefly these other
two and I'll skip a lot of slides with
these slides I can make them available
to anyone who wants to see them but this
is another one is having a human
centered model of how programmers solve
parallel programming problems that's
very important that's the patterns are
all about but it's not enough we need to
have a language of programmability now
this came to me as I was studying the
psychology of programming and if you
ever want an interesting read to go out
and search out the literature and the
psychology programming there's not a lot
of it which i think is tragic and i
think is a huge mistake because every
known programmer is a human being so you
would think that anybody who wants to
understand how to make programmers
effective we'd want to understand how
human beings go about programming but
there is remarkably little research
happening on that front after years of
working on the cognitive psychology
programming one of
one of the founders one of the real
leaders in that community Thomas green
came up with the idea that you know
coming up with a nice neat compact
cognitive model of human reasoning and
programming wasn't getting us anywhere
what we really need is just a way to
talk about how notations convey
information and he came up with this
thing called the cognitive dimensions
and there a way of laying out and
talking about the trade-offs you make in
choosing an information notation and how
they address the different problems in
using that information notation and in
describing something now one of the
famous papers about using cognitive
dimensions comes from a person I've
never met but I've read his paper many
times Steven Clark of a company I think
you've heard of called Microsoft but he
wrote a paper where he used cognitive
dimensions to analyze C sharp back in
the early days when C sharp was I think
still being developed and so I mean it's
it's a very it's been used for C sharp
it's been used for the design of remote
controls for televisions I mean
information notations can mean just
about anything now I've got a lot of
ideas a lot of material here that I
won't go through but let me just mention
one of the cognitive dimensions probably
my favorite one and I think it says a
lot about information notations this is
the idea the viscosity of an information
notation how easy is it to introduce
small changes to an existing parallel
program is how it applied here so look
at OpenMP I have this loop that I'm
parallelizing and don't worry if you
don't know OpenMP but you know I'm just
saying do this loop and parallel and do
a reduction in to some and you better
make the variable X private or you're
going to have a race condition okay if I
wanted to change the schedule because
this is a semantically neutral clause
except for this possibility for
introducing races but it's mostly
semantically neutral so I can just
change if I want to change the schedule
just by changing the schedule clause so
it's a very low viscosity notation
whereas if I did the same thing i'll get
to in a second whereas i did the same
thing in the win32 api and explicit
threat api I'm not picking on winds
windows but you know now I I have to fix
the schedule something I'm hardwiring
in there if i want to change to a from a
static to dynamic schedule i have to
make all sorts of changes so this is a a
more viscous notation now notice very
closely I didn't say one was bad and one
was good you know there's things I can
do with this high viscosity notation
that I can't do with that light
viscosity notation but it now gives me a
way to talk about them and talk about
the trade-offs between these two styles
and and and to make a productive
dialogue about that so now what got you
for the somatic venue yeah I know
they're they're relatively semantically
neutral yes yes a little Matt well then
there's all then then you put a
reduction in there and now you have the
the different orders and how you do the
the sums yeah I think the important
pieces to undress make a distinction
between thinking about abstractions
being used and baking there
language using some new signals so say
if I look at the success of
object-oriented patterns the real good
thing about them is not to require you
to change your language you can just use
object-oriented languages that are
already there and you can implement them
all right no new the same tax no need
nothing like that so I think what what
happens in the parallel or people
haven't read advance to the level
they're still revising the language
themselves I mean it should be we should
be talking about abstractions that can
be done on top of the option based
foundation that doesn't need to change
every time we think of anyway so I i'm
going to agree with you though maybe not
fully but i think my pattern language is
an attempt to write down that set of
abstractions and that as we iterate
through it and once we come up with the
right pattern language where we get
enough input from a broad enough array
of people that will give us the set of
abstractions and then we can start to
talk about with the language these
cognitive dimensions are all about
syntax and so it's a it's almost like i
have a complete radical change of
subject because now i'm not talking
abstractions anymore i'm really not much
i'm really talking about syntax but i
can't tell you enough to the boring
application programmer like me syntax
matters I've had computer scientists
tell me time and time again syntax
doesn't matter just get the semantics
right screw it no syntax matters see
this Apple on this computer it's there
because you change the api's on visual
studio and broke all my programs I've
never gone back to visual studio since
okay syntax matters i'm still pissed
about that you know you so this
cognitive dimensions is all about
describing syntax and because i know
you're way past your threshold I want to
get to this nice picture so there's a
whole range of these cognitive
dimensions and you know you can look
them up read the stephen clark paper you
if you google cognitive i'm sorry you
don't use google here at microsoft use
what's the microsoft cert live search UK
live search on cognitive dimensions and
you'll find there's a whole list of them
and once again it lets you i'm going to
show you this
one here it lets you productively
compare across programming languages and
i can say that yes openmp has a very low
viscosity MPI is a very high viscosity
I'm not saying good or bad i'm just
comparing them ok and i can go through
openmp because of that stupid shared
address space is very error-prone if
you've written significant openmp codes
you've written some ugly race conditions
and hopefully you have found them
whereas MPI actually you know MPI is
actually not that error-prone it's why
we like it it's it's pretty easy to get
my program correct I may have to do an
awful lot of work to decompose the data
structures and you know the point is
this gets us past one is good the other
bad and it gets us to a point where
we're talking about the features of it
language that make it good the features
of the language that make it bad so last
thing I want to say that I'm going to
shut up is we have metrics of
performance why don't we have metrics of
programmability we need standard
programmability benchmarks that we can
use and we argue about and my poster
child for this is the solution problems
I think some of you here have heard of
them yeah ah I love this and but but
it's old and dusty and I think we need
to update it and expand it and get a
broader community and what I'm thinking
of is what I'd like to happen is the
Berkeley folks did a really good job of
coming up with these 13 dwarves so what
I would like to do is get a group of
people together to define the 13
exemplars so we come up with a
programmability benchmark for each one
of these but in my mind a
programmability benchmark to be
effective has to be defined paper and
pencil like the solution problems but
there has to be a reference
implementation that is short and easy to
read because this is the key if I have
to read a 10,000 line program to compare
one programming notation to another I
can't even start but if i can compare of
200 to 500 line program and that means
we're kind of moving into the danger the
toy code area but i think we have to be
able to have these standard comparisons
that we can make it in programming
notation or we'll get nowhere
so that's all I had thank you so I just
closing what I really hope happens is we
can start working together and we could
you know think about it we have this
structure at Berkeley it's a great place
to come to work together where the
lawyers won't bug us but you know I want
us to work together on a pattern
language because we need as broad a
community as possible to make it work I
think we'd all benefit if we built a
discussion framework of programmability
the cognitive dimensions are a great
starting point and then I finally I
really would love to see us come
together and work on these these
standard programmability benchmarks and
I think if we don't do this chances are
we'll just add to that list of
programming languages and we won't
necessarily create anything that anyone
will use so thank you very much and
we're going to watch after this just
look at various of people there and I
think then what's the afternoon special
we have a mini Lego Marvel
2209 and we're gonna continue talking
about patterns them and that's when I
London to is on the danger cart set
arcelik want to do well I have one
question because I was going to ask you
a question on the metrics it seemed like
you get their top and slide you could
show us a little different than what I
was thinking as far as metric so as you
as you distill down right and you take a
higher level concept into the lower
level layers right how do you how do you
judge whether or not your choices of
that low level is a good to be
implementation how do you calculate
sergey the error the efficiency you know
how much you've lost or how much for
your head right now as you age breakdown
because you've got a lot of level to me
there even be in tech toys right or how
you implement one of the higher level
things and so how do you decide you know
whether you make the right choice wrong
turn Joyce what do you know right so how
do you decide as you move through the
layers of the pattern language that
you've made a right choice was the wrong
choice yet so there's two things to
point out in your question that that are
important to appreciate and one is that
there's no single path and that's that's
the issue how do you know you have the
right path I submit that it's iterative
you go down all the way through to the
lower layer now you have a stack of
paper with boxes and diagrams and little
notations and you get to the bottom you
go gee that was you know is there a
better way to do it and you have to
iterate back through it's not an
objective you know that you're going to
sign a numerical weight to each branch
along a tree and you can say oh yeah
this is the lowest cost path we're
talking about the human process it's
fundamentally iterative geometric a
higher level really into to judge the
branch chains are you bottom level then
you just have a performance scalability
area yeah yeah you get so that you get
to the bottom and will usually you know
because we're talking about software
design so so you know hopefully you get
to this before you start having code
running and performed and performance
metrics but you know the whole idea is
you get down a design cycle is it
exposing much concurrency and if you
look at my book we talked a great deal
about that iterative nature of how much
concurrency are you exposing is this
reasonable relevant to the
target platforms you know we like to
talk about being architectural in
neutral but fundamentally at some point
you have to break that architectural
detail to neutrality and think that gee
I'm going to be on a Windows platform
with a laptop with a 16 core processor
but it is it is iterative and and it's
fascinating to me if you do look at the
psychology of programming that iterative
nature comes out and study after study
after study that we teach people in
school a top-down method of software
architecture but the fact is that no
good professional program or programs
that way they they always the really
good productive ones they always sort of
iterate down a little bit then jump back
up then iterate down again then jump
back up and therefore a notation and a a
framework that supports them has to
support that iteration